de allí bukele a una elección del
control total del salvador nuevas ideas
el movimiento del presidente que por
primera vez se presenta unas
legislativas es favorito para conseguir
el control absoluto de la asamblea un
hecho que agrada en un país en el que el
presidente cuenta con más de un 70% de
popularidad pero que preocupa
internacionalmente la oposición y ongs
como acción ciudadana aseguran que si
busquen le vence estos comicios se
perdería la posibilidad de frenar
cualquier intento de abuso que quiera
cometer el ejecutivo y como se
instrumentalizó la fuerza armada la
seguridad pública las instituciones
dictaba al suelo
mi día desde el frente farabundo martí
para la liberación nacional que gobernó
el país entre 2009 y 2019 es la
institucionalización de la guerrilla que
se ha alternado el poder junto al
derechista arena tras el final de la
guerra en 1992 unos partidos que han
perdido credibilidad después de 30 años
salpicados por la corrupción en los que
no han mejorado las condiciones de vida
de los salvadoreños
bukele fue el alcalde de sant salvador
con el fmln sin embargo en 2019
consiguió presentarse en solitario
ilusión acción plan no tener el control
de la asamblea no ha podido avanzar en
su agenda nombrar jueces fiscales y
sacar de las instituciones las voces más
críticas una limitación que le llevó el
9 de febrero de 2020 a militarizar el
congreso después de que no le aprobarse
en un plan de financiación de la lucha
contra el crimen
precisamente esa lucha está entre sus
bazas electorales tras haber bajado el
crimen de 50 homicidios por cada 100.000
habitantes a 19 homicidios en sólo 20
meses